Sam Smith's the cast of Victorious and
all of their crazy storylines but just
how much of their on-screen drama
translated into their real lives did any
of the cast members date and are they
still dating today we've got all the
details about the real-life
relationships of the victorious cast
keep watching to find out which cast
member dated someone 20 years older than
her so you wanna break up no I didn't
say that I'm just saying you guys might
write that ariana grande is by far the
most successful star of Victorious she
has gone on to become a popular
award-winning singer but Nickelodeon
fans will always remember her as the
lovable Cat Valentine
ariana has been in the public eye for a
long time and all of her relationships
are being covered by the media so let's
take a look at her dating history before
the show when she was just a teenager
she dated actor Graham Phillips the two
met when they were in the Broadway show
13 the musical but when Victoria started
the two were just too busy to keep
seeing each other
there's still close friends though she
then dated Jay from the Janoskians in
2012 but that relationship was messy he
accused her of cheating on him with a
member of the boy band The Wanted she
never confirmed whether this was true or
not but it was all over Twitter her next
relationship was with Big Sean the
rapper but his ex-fiance Naya Rivera
accused Big Sean of cheating on her with
Arianna Arianna fans were so glad when
she began dating the late-night Miller
they were good friends for three years
before they made it official it seemed
like it was destined to last but
substance abuse and other determining
factors got in the way of their
relationship she then dated Pete
Davidson and got engaged within a month
they were only together for a few months
though and after Mack passed away they
called their engagement off there are
rumors that ariana is now dating Mikey
Foster but it's hard to know if these
are reliable okay
Robbie Shapiro was one of the best
characters on Victorious his character
was shy at first but he really managed
to come out of his shell not Bennett has
also developed into a very talented
individual before victorious he starred
in a movie produced by Will Ferrell's
called the virginity hit he also had a
role in the hit comedy bridesmaids he's
done some acting since the Nickelodeon
show ended but he decided to take his
talents to Nerdist he hosts a youtube
show for them called nerdy jobs in 2016
he released a studio album that he wrote
himself it was inspired by both his
parents divorce and Robin Williams's
movies that has kept his personal life
on the down-low ever since he started
acting there are no records of him
dating anyone but many people suspected
that he dated elizabeth gillies in
Ariana Grande however he's just close
friends with both of his former co-stars
he even starred in two of Ariana's music
videos yeah you see how one lie leads to
another he might not be as big of a
household name as Victoria Justice or
Ariana Grande but Leon Thomas the third
is one of the more successful stars of
Victoria's on the show he played Andre
Harris I want to go play with Chico but
he was doing big things before he ever
got that role he started on Broadway at
age 10 with the major role of young
Simba in the Lion King he's saying in
the movie August Rush and was the
singing voice of Tyrone in the backyard
against he's continued to act since
victorious ended but he's also gotten
into music production he's produced
mixtapes and singles
he's one half of the production team the
rascals he even co-produced post
Malone's album stoney he also helped
ariana grande write songs for her first
album he's just all-around talented but
no one knows anything about his dating
history he's managed to hide his love
interest from publications you can see
Leon in the upcoming show frack stir
handsome do I not have a happy go skip
your personality
have you ever wondered what happened to
singe in Van Cleave well wonder no more
Sinjin was played by Michael Eric Reid
who also goes by Mikey Sinjin he played
a super creepy stalkerish character hey
girls
thankfully mikey is nothing like that in
real life he's actually a talented actor
he's acted in a few indie films
including mama boy most recently he was
in Bob Freeman exterminator for hire
mikey has kept all the details about his
personal life out of the limelight some
sources say he's had at least one
relationship but there's no word on who
it was
he's not active on social media either
he's still acting but otherwise mikey is
a bit of a mystery disco you know her as
Trina Vega Tori's less talented sister
but in real life Daniela is very
talented the 31 year old started acting
back in the 90s
she became well known for the role in
the show listen up back in 2004 she has
continued to act since victorious ended
Trina or tarney but she also maintains
the fitness and lifestyle website that
is really popular Daniela has been
dating Andrew Gardner since 2010 they
dated for seven years before getting
engaged their engagement story is one of
the cutest Daniela had a popular YouTube
vlog Andrew set up a plan to surprise
her and propose while she was filming
she was totally shocked he carved the
question in a tree when she turned
around he was down on one knee with a
ring last September Daniela and Andrew
welcomed their first child Gio since Gio
was born she and Andrew have started a
podcast called adulting like a mother
father keep watching to find out who
everyone's favorite on-screen couple is
dating today yeah Cici oh that's a
gorgeous address
do you remember toys guidance counselor
mr. Lane Alexander he was on a bunch of
episodes of victorious and he was such a
great character
mr. Alexander was played by Lane Napper
he also played the dance teacher on
iCarly he's a talented guy that was a
bunch of hats he does a lot more than
just act Lane is a very well renowned
choreographer while he was only on 19
episodes of victorious he was the
choreographer for 42 episodes
Lane continues to be a choreographer he
acts occasionally appearing in small
roles on shows like Jessica Jones and
the good cop Lane also works as a
dialogue coach and an acting coach
he's worked as a dialogue coach with
huge stars like John Ritter George Lopez
and Hulk Hogan we can't find any
confirmation about a relationship
although some sites suggest he might
have been married at some point either
way he's a busy career driven guy and
according to Trina every one of you was
with her at some point just before the
show Victorious heartthrob of angela is
up next
Alvin might have been shipped with
elizabeth gillies while they were on the
show but most likely these were just
rumors man you make me happy in 2012
Alvin began dating actress Zooey did you
know her from her starring role on
Vampire Academy they dated for five
years eventually ending things in 2017
they kept their relationship details out
of the press preferring to stay private
they appear to have had an amicable
breakup and even starred in Zombieland
double tap together last year currently
he's dating Cleopatra Jolie the two
dressed up as Angelina Jolie and Billy
Bob Thornton for the Zombieland premiere
we hope their relationship doesn't end
like Angelina and Billy Bob's he will be
in a new movie called the exchange which
is in post-production he does a lot of
activism for the LGBTQ community he
co-founded a nonprofit called Straight
But Not Narrow the goal is to help
straight people understand and empathize
with the queer community the costume
designer was in your dressing room
uh-huh
was she cute he was adorable
you know we had to include mr. sicko
it's it's hard to imagine Eric as
anything but the crazy acting teacher at
Hollywood Arts Eric had acted for a long
time before victorious but that role
really made him famous I should just
walk out that door never do it sir he
went on to have a major role in narcos
currently he's filming a brand new
series called brand new cherry flavour
he also had a recurring role in the
critically acclaimed series man in the
high castle but we bet you didn't know
that while sicka wits was up in his
shenanigans eric was finding love he'd
fell in love with a sales rep named Lisa
Sabatino in 2013 just after Victoria's
ended the two tied the knot wait why are
we talking about proms you might know
her as Fallon Carrington on dynasty but
in our hearts elizabeth gillies will
always be Jade West if Elizabeth stated
when she was on the show she kept it
under wraps that didn't stop the rumor
mill though there was a lot of
speculation that she was dating her
victorious co-star Matt Bennett
they were always posting pictures on
social media together but they never
confirmed their relationship so they
were likely just great friends there
were also plenty of people who shipped
Elizabeth with her on-screen love
interest of enjoy gia look great I know
but like Matt these two are probably
just great friends Elizabeth did date
actor Logan Miller for a few months in
2011 in 2016 Elizabeth confirmed via
Twitter that she was dating songwriter
Michael Corcoran he also goes by the
name Backhouse Mike Mike wrote a lot of
the music for Nickelodeon shows
including victorious this relationship
came as a shock because Mike is over 20
years older than Elizabeth for Mike and
Elizabeth age is nothing but a number
you could say I'm pretty
you are pretty wrapping up this list is
none other than the star of Victorious
Victoria justice has a long dating
history in fact she had her first
boyfriend when she was just 10 years old
she and Cole Sprouse had to be the most
adorable preteen couple ever Cole was
actually her first smooch but it wasn't
romantic it was on the set of The Suite
Life of Zack and Cody
what a way to have that important first
experience as a teenager Victoria dated
Hunger Games star Josh Hutcherson for
about a year then she met Ryan Rotman on
the set of Victorious and the two dated
for two years after she and Ryan moved
on Victoria starred in the romantic
comedy Naomi and Ely's no-kiss list she
fell in love with her co-star Pierson
Foday these two actors dated for a
couple of years they took a break but
never got back together in 2016 she
started dating another co-star this time
from the live version of the Rocky
Horror Picture Show she began dating
Reeve Carney and the couple have worked
hard to keep their dating life out of
the media it's unclear if they're still
together and that's a wrap which actors
relationship history surprised you the
most let us know in the comments I know
it'll make you feel better
jumping jacks thanks for watching give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to the things that
you next time